all right
wow what a way to celebrate I just can't
ask for anything more RAM Charan star of
RR the first ever Indian feature film to
win an Oscar goes all out for his 38th
birthday in an over-the-top celebration
back home check out this look inside the
festivities India's leading man of the
moment showered by pink rose petals
which some believe symbolize love
gratitude and appreciation
[Music]
everything from here is just another
feather on the heart it's it's just a
it's just everything is extra right now
just enjoying the moment just to be here
as RAM tries to cut his cake it becomes
buried under the flowers so much so that
he asked the excited crowd to pause so
he can take a bite foreign
[Applause]
rounding out the celebration a
breathtaking fireworks display yes yes
on top of experiencing International
crossover success
ROM has a lot to be proud of as he looks
ahead to the next year he's expecting
his first child with his wife Long View
I've been waiting for 10 years I've been
married for 10 years I think we've found
time and on the hills of RR success he's
got another film coming out game changer
[Music]
the trailer was his birthday gift to
fans the cinema is becoming a global
Cinema it's no more Hollywood Bollywood
it's burning all the woods and becoming
a global cinnamon I'm I'm so fortunate
to be part of that
ET was with the actor just ahead of
Natsu nachos Academy Award win
and he was revved up for his Hollywood
future I want to be in every franchise
where people are really watching and
buying that ticket I want to be in every
film in every country where people
appreciate art in the films and Cinema
basically well cheers to that ROM seems
like you're well on your way
[Music]
thank you